[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radio Francia internacional y de
France 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
Irán envuelto en una espiral de
protestas con los derechos y libertades
de las mujeres en su trasfondo nos
acompañan en este estudio orian verdier
periodista en el servicio internacional
de recí que fue excoresponsable en el
kurdistán bienvenido arian Gracias
21 bienvenida
saranes periodista independiente
fotógrafo que conoce Bien también el
tema del kurdistán bienvenido Buenos
días y Catalina Gómez en dúplex desde
pera en nuestra corresponsal de recibo
Buenos días Buenos días Muchísimas
gracias por por invitarme y un placer
estar con ustedes
las movilizaciones en Irán hoy nuestro
asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
movilizaciones que se han convertido en
una repulsa el sistema teocrático acaba
de concluir el periodo de luto de 40
días por la muerte de la joven masa mini
la joven de 22 años que murió bajo
custodia policial detenida por llevar
mal colocado el velo por la policía de
la moral desde el fallecimiento de amini
las manifestaciones han congregado a
miles de iraníes sobre todo mujeres y
jóvenes Bajo lemas como mujer vida y
libertad o muerde al dictador en alusión
al máximo líder iraní el ayatolá alija
minei repasemos algunas portadas que nos
deja este asunto algunas tan icónicas
como esta del cougué Gaga internacional
con una mujer cortando la barba a la
ayatolá que la oprime bajo el titular el
régimen contra el muro en España el
diario ABC la rebelión de los velos las
mujeres desafían al régimen ayatolá tras
la muerte de amini y se quitan el jillab
en una protesta que se extiende por el
mundo este artículo del irán a
International lleva por título el
régimen clerical incapacitado para
negociar con la llamada generación vamos
a hablar de ese factor de juventud en
las protestas y esta portada del New
York Times la más reciente toca las
movilizaciones de esta semana por tras
los 40 días de luto por amina bueno
orión Hasta qué punto estas protestas
podemos decir que están fragilizando al
régimen hablamos de un verdadero punto
de no retorno Pues sí de hecho ahora
justo ahora estábamos viendo que pasaron
los 40 días después de la muerte de masa
Mini y desde el comienzo lo vemos día a
día que no se para o sea estas estamos
esperando de saber si iba a durar parece
que dura y también está en diferentes
clases de la sociedad está integrada
está en provincias está en clases más
pobres en clases más más ricas entonces
parece que dure y también se ve que los
jóvenes dicen que están listos para
morir o sea solo quieren que las cosas
cambien Y eso nos hace pensar que igual
iba a seguir pero siempre estamos
esperando para ver el futuro no hace un
mes hubiéramos pensado bueno el régimen
acabará con la estaferosopresión
acabarán las protestas pero no las
semanas pasan y las protestas continúan
sí a propósito del punto de nombre
retorno hay un punto que me parece muy
interesante que cuando nos vemos en los
vídeos en las redes sociales
parecen más y más mujeres que se filman
sin el velo islámico y en eso me parece
que un punto de donde el entorno que el
velo islámico ahora hoy en Irán no es
más el
símbolo que estuve en los años 80 y sí
claro que bueno el régimen es muy fuerte
en Irán que los conservadores controlan
a todas
suscripciones pero sí que tenemos una
una juventud que de una cierta manera no
tiene mucho que perder es que llama
mucho ese punto la juventud estamos
viendo gente de 11 de 12 años es decir
adolescentes está muy conectado a lo
mejor fueron los hijos de los padres que
salieron a las calles en el principio de
los años 2000 los nietos lo hagan un
punto de no retorno
es difícil de desierro Pues de momento
es difícil saber si el régimen está
totalmente desacralizado
porque lleva 40 años y estas cosas sí
que losa de hacer en 2019 la gente salió
a la calle porque los precios de la
carne o del arroz eran terribles las
familias vivían una situación económica
terrible según varias fuentes estas
manifestaciones se concluirán por una
cifra terrible de más de 1.500 Muertos o
sea y gente que estaba manifestando
porque tenían hambre hoy es este este
movimiento va más allá porque en la era
el velo Perdón es es un símbolo de este
de este régimen y es un símbolo de dos
poderes y ranis el poder
político y el poder religioso Así que es
casi seguro que este régimen no va a dar
nada para para comprar una Paz en este
país a seguir en este en este día Pero
sabemos que este este este sistema este
régimen y raño está preparado Está bueno
tiene entre sus manos todos los poderes
para matar a cualquier Revolución bueno
la represión está siendo muy feroz lo
estamos viendo esos días Incluso se está
incrementando
2019 se hablaba de 200 muertos al inicio
y al final son más de 1.500 Así que
sabremos dentro de dos o tres meses
igual cuantas muertos en las calles
porque claro ahora las cifras es muy
difícil calcularlos las autoridades
iraníes no informan según la ong iraní
en el exilio Irán Human Rights con sede
en oslo los muertos son al menos al
Menos 215 incluidos 27 niños y los
detenidos 12.500 lo que pasa claro es
tan complicado que
aproximarse esas cifras y saber cómo son
estas cifras en realidad Bueno vamos a
conectar en este punto con nuestra
corresponsal enteran con Catalina Gómez
a pesar de una represión feroz como
decíamos las protestas continúan
simplemente la presión de las mujeres y
la violencia son La chispa pero las
protestas indican un profundo malestar
que quizá vaya más allá un malestar que
une varios factores podríamos decir no
Catalina
muy importante para para mirar que una
de las maneras que como sigue
protestando la población en las mujeres
Cómo se han dejado caer el velo y a
pesar del temor pues lo antes ya veíamos
mujeres sin velo caído caminando por la
calle pero siempre con el velo aquí
ahora vemos muchísimas más incluso sin
el velo puesto lo llevan en la cartera o
algunas ni siquiera los llevan en la
cartera en una manera también de
protestar contra esto pero obviamente el
velo es simplemente un símbolo de todo
lo que son estas protestas no solamente
partían de la violencia que trae esa
policía de la moral y esa represión que
hace el estado contra la población
especialmente la sienten los jóvenes esa
represión no solamente viene a la
policía la moral si no vienen de esos
cuerpos paramilitares o que apoyan al al
sistema como los basilis esos de boyacá
sí que hemos estos hombres vestidos de
civil que hemos visto en la calle
entonces obviamente todo esto es una es
una bomba se van uniendo elementos
sumado obviamente Esta no es una
protesta que surge por razones
económicas pero si hay una indignación
por la situación económica por la falta
de esperanzas de posibilidades de futuro
que sobre todo lo ven en este caso como
lo vemos reflejado los jóvenes entonces
todo esto es como una Unión de muchos
factores que terminó por explotar cuando
muere maxa mini eh por esta abuso de la
policía de la moral en una porque todo
el mundo sabe que tan violentos y que
tan abusivo son velo caído como símbolo
de algo que va mucho más allá decía
nuestra corresponsal una suma de
elementos una bomba claro quizá que está
el elemento o el sentimiento de que no
hay nada que perder y con ese
sentimiento de que no hay nada que
perder quizá esa sea el arma más potente
no contra el
Sí también para volver sobre el caso de
los jóvenes estaba hablando con una
mujer de Teherán que tiene 30 años y me
decía que la gran diferencia entre ella
y los jóvenes de ahora de 20 o 15 años
es que ella sus padres no les les
apoyaban cuando salían en la calle a
decir que no querían el velo que querían
cambio de régimen porque sus padres
todavía creían un poco o no querían
reconocer que la revolución islámica no
era la solución verdadera para Irán pero
a la diferencia ahora que los jóvenes
También tienen sus padres que los apoyan
primero y también claro crecieron con el
internet abierto Claro que Irán el
régimen Control pero ahora tiene muchas
maneras para para así pasar por otros
vías para llegar a todos los sitios de
internet en donde todo el mundo va
entonces creo también eso es lo que hace
que la bomba no puede volver a entrar en
la caja porque está abierta y no no
puede hacer nada el régimen claro puede
como seguir O sea no hay que olvidar su
violencia y su capacidad a controlar
pero creo que de verdad algo cambió en
esa manera también erra bueno decir lo
único que lo que vemos hoy es de una
cierta manera la consecuencia de la
política o de la Revolución islámica que
tenemos una juventud iraní que es
educada que se va a la universidad que
vemos muchos muchísimos estudiantes
bueno porque hay cuatro millones de
estudiantes en Irán que todo el mundo se
va a la universidad hoy en Irán Y
entonces esa política de educar a la a
la a la juventud que que fue una de las
prioridades de las
del de régimen islámico bueno se vea la
consecuencia también
hablar de para hablar de que una gente
que no tiene nada que perder porque esas
personas que tienen menos de 25 años que
aún no trabajan aún no tiene nada
responsabilidad económica o familiar y
entonces no es la regeneración de bueno
25 Entre 25 y 40 años que está en el
mercado de trabajo es etcétera que tiene
miedo a ellos no tiene miedo que
crecieron contar con el interés y con
las redes sociales y a ellos solo
quieren libertad claro además la
responsabilidad es en la vida te dan
cierto miedo a veces respecto a las
cosas no es entendible también no sé qué
tanto pesa el hecho de que más a
proveniera del kurdistán iraní Logan
Cómo calibramos el hecho es difícil
saberlo
los kurdos con quien hable hace poco en
el curso y dicen que ha sido matado
porque porque era kurda
pues como periodista yo no puedo hacia
tomarlo no sé luego lo que se lo que se
sabe es que las provincias del curry
están Y del balusistán que son dos
minorías étnicas y religiosas tienen un
tratamiento especial de la parte de las
fuerzas de represión y aranís la policía
el ejército o los cuerpos de seguridad
iraníes no disparan de la misma manera
en
esa edad en Andalucía en el curiosistant
o enteran Sí eso es cierto Bueno luego
lo de lo demás de momento es complicado
hacer armarlo es un movimiento
haya sido de utilidad que
seis días lo creo que después de las del
asesinado de más a mini fue una huelga
en el curiosidades que fue una represión
terrible contra los vendedores que dicen
la huelga en el kurdistán
de Irán es históricamente también un
lugar de rebelión en contra del régimen
Entonces está organizado y encuentra con
el movimiento feminista iraní los dos se
unen y creo que eso hace la fuerza y
también el feminismo
encurtistán es muy fuerte el eslogan
mujer vida y Libertad viene de yin yang
ayadi que es de kurdistán entonces creo
que sí no se puede calcular exactamente
cómo pero es seguro que los dos se unen
y hacen fuerza luego recojo Este hilo
que después de la pausa que propone
Oriana y también os voy crear lo que
pasó hace 10 años las primaveras árabes
Cuánto tiene de semejanza y cuánto de
diferencia Cuántos comparable Y cuánto
no esto que estamos viendo ahora
volvemos enseguida
[Música]
France 24 la economía día a día
egalité actualité
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más importantes de
los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de 24
enlace en francés 24 y France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana hablando de la
espiral de movilizaciones en Irán y lo
hablaremos y lo hacemos con las
periodistas a orión verdier Sara Aguirre
piñá y nuestra corresponsal Catalina
Gómez desde Terán es un movimiento sin
dirigentes ya hemos conocido estallidos
de esa índole durante las primaveras
árabes recuerdan hace 11 años se vale la
comparación o es muy distinta a la
situación actual más de una década
después sarra Bueno
estamos 11 años después de la primavera
árabe Entonces
nos hemos
visto el fallecimiento de esas
revoluciones y eso es hace una gran
diferencia Porque por ejemplo por los
100 años que se ven lo que sucedió en
Siria y en Libia y en Egipto Y entonces
Me parece que sería sería un poco
difícil de hacerla con la comparación
con lo que sucede en los Países Árabes y
también que Irán es un país que tiene
instrucciones muy fuertes y como lo
hemos dicho que los conservadores
controlan y algo más
La mayoría de la población iraní no es
joven que no tienen menos de 30 años y
me parece que eso hace también una
diferencia porque cuando lo más joven es
lo más que tiene nada que perder que
tiene que que o que quiere que sí
entonces bueno eso también hace una gran
diferencia Logan como ven La diferencia
posible por el contexto internacional y
por el papel los Estados Unidos porque
está esta crisis lo que está ocurriendo
ahora mismo en Irán tiene raíces
profundas y una de estas raíces es el
acuerdo sobre el nuclear y iraní que ha
sido firmado por los Estados Unidos por
Barack Obama en 2015 y que abandonó otro
Eso ha provocado muchas cosas y una
crisis económica terrible hay si hay una
comparación posible es más con países de
la tienda America creo porque este este
contexto internacional hay
interdependencias entre entre estos
países y su actitud particularmente los
Estados Unidos pues tienen un papel muy
importante en esta historia y creo que
la reacción del
régimen iraní es de protegerse para
luchar contra las injerencias
extranjeras cuando el régimen iraní toma
el enemigo externo para justificar todo
es decir Estados Unidos Israel que
intenta estabilizar el país y es por
ello Es decir hacer digamos la causa
efecto este discurso está hasta qué
punto cala en Irán en estos momentos
hasta que hasta qué punto es claro es
complicado no calibrarlo no hasta qué
punto los iraníes la opinión pública era
ni compra este discurso Sara
el enemigo externo sí se compra ese
discurso pero que de verdadero es que
sabemos que las las restricciones
internacionales y las secciones
económicas y lo que sucede con el
tratado nuclear bueno que de verdadero
tuve consecuencias reales económicas y
eso fue una de las consecuencias que
bueno de que los conservadores
[Música]
sucedieron a las elecciones el año
pasado y entonces Que bueno no hay una
conspiración del enemigo exterior y
también hay algún otro punto que ahí los
las operaciones de hacking que se hacen
por ejemplo los israelís Y entonces hay
verdaderas amenazas extranjeras y lo que
lo que se debe entender y es que me aún
la pongo la población no va a comprar
Ese discurso de la gran comparación
internacional
desde la presión que está utilizada por
régimen desde siempre la amena se
exterior y la instrumentalización de
estas manifas como si la gente en las
calles estaba manipulada por los Estados
Unidos y Israel creo que también hay que
entender que que los iraníes pueden
hacer la diferencia reconocer que
Estados Unidos también son injustos con
Irán y con la población de Irán que les
están imponiendo sanciones que les hacen
pobres pero también
régimen es corrupto y es muy autoritario
y que y que no pueden vivir más con ese
régimen y creo que nosotros tenemos que
entender esto también que es más
complejo porque creo que los iraníes
ellos si entendieron muy bien y
analizaron muy bien sobre todo A lo
mejor una población joven que sí que
tiene esa capacidad de sentido crítico
no con lo que está pasando y esa de
diferenciar lo que está diciendo Oriana
en varios planos volvemos en este punto
a Teherán con nuestra corresponsal
Catalina para trasladarse están para
trasladarle la misma cuestión de la que
hablábamos ya en 2009 vimos protestas
muy interesantes tras los selecciones y
luego en 2019 contra el alza de los
precios del petróleo y la vida Cara
también en 2017 hace poco hubo una serie
de manifestaciones por el costo de la
vida es un nuevo episodio
esa inconformidad no solamente cada vez
es mayor lo que se muestran las
protestas en el 2009 pues las fueron muy
grandes Pero todas tenían una razón
política En aquel momento todavía había
una convicción de que se podían hacer
reformas y cambios dentro de la
estructura de la política de la de la
república islámica Y en eso era muy
importante y por eso ellos pedían que
volvieran a recontarse los votos que
volvieran a hacer selecciones porque
Ellos pensaban que a través de esos
líderes políticos Se podrían hacer
reformas luego ya vimos pues una gran
represión esas protestas duraron casi
siete meses los líderes habían líderes
políticos quedaron en casa por cárcel
sus jóvenes son el resultado de esos
padres que hicieron esas protestas en el
2009 o esos hermanos y lo que hemos
visto a partir de ahí fueron otras
protestas llamadas ligadas con el campo
económico vimos las sanciones como se
hicieron mayores
el estado iraní el
régimen iraní cada vez fue más corrupto
la situación económica la corrupción el
desgaste del régimen el el fin de las
posibilidades de de la política como una
opción de cambio porque Obviamente el
régimen también se encargó de cerrarle
todas las puertas a un movimiento
reformista que en algún momento Tuvo una
gran posibilidad en el país sumado a lo
que ya vemos ahora una nueva generación
que creció en el internet que quiere
tener una vida normal como la que tiene
jóvenes en el resto del mundo que
quieren tener esperanzas y posibilidades
sino y especialmente las mujeres sin un
régimen diciéndoles cómo tienen que
comportarse Y cómo tienen que hacer su
vida lo que vemos entonces son digamos
dos cosas que confluyen más en un
periodo más corrupción del régimen más
desgaste menos ilusión por una esperanza
aunque fuera reformista y también desde
fuera más presión internacional y lo que
confluyen son digamos los dos factores
el interno y el externo no Ori Sí
también hoy en la forma se ve diferencia
con 2019 como lo explico Catalina porque
ahora todo el mundo mueve no es solo en
2019 era más gente pobre ahora es todo
el mundo y también te eran nueve y eso
da miedo al régimen porque sabe que te
harán es mucho más complicado
controlarlo y también vemos mucho más lo
que pasa por ejemplo Ahora si te das
cuenta solo hablamos o mucho hablamos de
Teherán sabemos mucho más las videos que
vemos muchas veces están enteran cuando
en otras provincias como en baluchistán
o en kurdistán están pasando cosas y
tenemos mucho más dificultad tener
informaciones Entonces el régimen sabe
que sí viene a tener que Matar o en
Teherán Pues todo el mundo lo va a saber
y va a ser mucho más complicado
de formas distintas en la capital que
nuestra que en otras regiones verdad
claro realmente en las minorías étnicas
y religiosas como los baruches y los
euros eso es factual se nota en las
cifras que tenemos Aunque estas cifras
no son nada nada completas pero sí Y es
un miedo para el régimen iraní de ver
que estas minoridades que no tienen un
sentimiento nacional muy fuerte se están
uniendo y los mensajes en la capital en
las manifestaciones enteran diciendo que
hermanos y hermanas de kurdistán y de
valosistant estáis con nosotros eso son
cosas que se dicen en las manifas se
enteran dan aún más miedo al régimen y
arañi que se ve casi está rodeado de
amenazas una amenaza de su juventud que
no tiene más confió en los viejos que
dirigen este país más las minoridades
árabes porque también hay una minoría
rara vez curvas y baruchis pues es una
situación crítica para el régimen lo
curioso es que pues sí
también una diferencia a las fuerzas
estaciones de 2009 por ejemplo que es
una dificultad suplementar es que en
2009 había una alternativa política
había el candidato musabi con las
elecciones y dónde está mi voto etcétera
Pero es la gran dificultad y en eso es
quizás un punto de proximidad con las
manifestaciones de las de las primaveras
árabes que no hay una alternativa
Y eso es no es contraproducente que
cámara harrishibaiden muestren su apoyo
o que macron condene las vio la
violencia para aumentar esa retórica por
parte del poder de la presunta
desestabilización es decir los apoyos
externos
de qué lado A qué lado favorecen es
complicado
también fue criticado porque porque vio
al presidente ride Sí y le habló
Entonces
él está jugando un poco en el medio
intentando quedarse y no entrar pero
creo que al momento o sea tienen están
obligadas también a a decir condenar lo
que pasa pero sí hay diferencia entre
tomar sanciones por ejemplo o solo decir
que con Danna creo que de todas maneras
el régimen va a tener el discurso que va
a tener Y de nuevo Yo creo que ahora los
iraníes no creen más en esto y de hecho
hablando sobre el discurso también de
régimen y las minoridades
uno de los discursos de régimen es que
las minoridades son separatistas y que
van a acabar con Irán Y eso también es
lo que es lo que da miedo creo que a
régimen Porque ve que hay movimiento
nacional y de verdad
los cursos iraníes con quién hablé ellos
son o sea se presentan como iraníes y
creen en este país Y claro hay quieren
también
tal vez algo como Federal o algo pero
pero si creen en este país están todos
juntos luchando para este país de
Teherán avaruchistán accurdistán
es muy importante de que las razones de
apoyo de parte de los Estados Unidos de
la Unión Europea por ejemplo
es la última cosa que necesitan los
cierran y realmente porque está estas
palabras fuertes si sean
están utilizadas por
régimen en contra de la población y una
cosa muy muy interesante hace un día el
estado islámico herpendicu un atentado
una mezquita de sierras y la primera
cosa que dijo rizzi Es que la culpa la
tenéis los manifestantes porque pones el
país que hacía riesgo hay mucho rollo en
todo el país y en una parte es la
consecuencia de vuestra actitud pues
muchísimas gracias me quedo ya sin
tiempo para más porque se nos agotó ya
media hora de programa hablando de Irán
y de las movilizaciones Muchísimas
gracias a los tres ha sido un placer
Logan Sara y orian y a nuestra
corresponsal entera en Catalina todos
ustedes hasta la próxima semana en
Primera Plana gracias